Один лише паркан відділяє українське Мілове, де я зараз знаходжуся, від російського Черткового.
Та ще й проходить вулицею Дружби народів. Паркан цей з'явився лише кілька років тому
і, як не парадоксально, був побудований росіянами. До цього протягом багатьох років
навіть після анексії Криму місцеві мешканці переходили з України в Росію
і з Росії в Україну в обхід пропускних пунктів, часто навіть не пред'являючи документи.
У небезпеку військового вторгнення в цьому регіоні місцеві мешканці кажуть,
що готові будуть повірити лише тоді, коли побачать танки біля своїх будинків.
Ця брудна дорога колись була міжнародним переходом між Україною і Росією.
А для Галини та інших місцевих, в яких рідні та друзі по обидва боки кордону - порятунком.
Я гляну, який дріт…
Ой, ясно… І колючий і такий…
Це смуга така прорита, щоб не переходили. Будуть ловити.
Декілька знаків, якась огорожа і натягнутий колючий дріт - можливо,
це і не виглядає як добре захищений кордон між двома конфліктуючими країнами,
але це, безумовно, великі зміни для місцевих жителів, які ще кілька років тому
могли проїхати тут, навіть не пред'являючи паспорти.
Тут є мужик - живе у Діброві. Його мати тут унизу в селі живе.
Оце до неї тут 6 кілометрів, а він об’їжджає кругом через митницю.
Коли кілька років тому огорожу тільки збудували, розповідає Галина,
родичі приходили та вставали по обидва боки, щоб поговорити через колючий дріт.
Саме через цю близькість і особисті зв'язки багато хто тут не готовий повірити,
що збройний конфлікт з Росією взагалі можливий.
Просто ми чуємо по телевізору, що там робиться. Якось страшно десь, але тут у нас,
здається, нас воно не зачепить з нашими цими земляками.
Можливо, це і так, але танки та війська Росії все ще на тому ж місці - за 200 кілометрів
від цього прикордонного села. І джерела в оборонному відомстві США
попереджають, що вторгнення може стати реальністю уже протягом кількох місяців.
Вірогідність російського вторгнення ми чекаємо з 2014 року.
Росія брязкає своїми м’язами постійно. За рахунок цього вони намагаються
вирішити свої питання на політичній арені.
Поки що командувач українськими силами на Сході країни не вважає війну неминучою.
Але якщо збройний конфлікт таки розпочнеться, він переконаний,
що війська США чи НАТО не стануть на захист України.
Ми сподіваємося тільки на себе. Було б дуже непогано, якби нам допомогли хоча б зброєю.
Тому якщо створити потужний повітряний щит, то про агресію
тоді можна буде так, із сумнівом казати.
У прикордонному містечку Мілове російські та українські прикордонники
знаходяться на відстані ледь не одного метра один від одного.
Кордон тут проходить центральною вулицею, яка досі називається "вулицею дружби"
- навіть після всього, що сталося між двома країнами.
Але навіть тут,
де багато місцевих дивляться на Росію зі своїх вікон, найбільше переймаються
пандемією коронавірусу та економічними проблемами, а не російськими танками.
У нас немає небезпеки. Як може бути небезпека, якщо ми от - ми поруч.
Якщо будуть стояти танки, тоді, звісно, буде небезпека і ми будемо хвилюватися.
Танків ми, слава Богу, не бачимо і, дай Бог, не побачимо.
Небезпеки, загрози немає ніякої. Нормально.
Танки не біля цих же кордонів.  Вони ж на кордоні вище Києва. Там.
Ми цього не бачимо, не чуємо. По телефону запитуємо. Нічого такого.
Ніякої напруги проти нас. Ані техніки, ані думок.
Я по телевізору тільки і чую, що танки. А так їх же не видно й не чути.
Ні, ні, немає в нас непорозумінь.
Поки Вашингтон і Москва обговорюють шляхи вирішення цієї прикордонної напруги,
люди на Сході України, схоже, не хочуть вірити, що загроза війни є реальною,
поки вони не побачать докази на власні очі.
Загроза вторгнення в Україну з боку Росії залишається головною темою переговорів
між США та Росією й після відеоконференції Джо Байдена і Володимира Путіна.
На думку німецького експерта Штефана Майстера, для Росії ані у військовому,
ані в стратегічному плані немає сенсу вторгатися в Україну. У цьому випадку
ціна для Кремля може виявитися надто високою, тому що з 2014 року багато що змінилося.
Метою було чинити тиск на Зеленського, в тому числі і через його політику щодо Медведчука
та деяких інших олігархів. Крім того, чинити тиск на американців
через тему розширення НАТО і змусити їх розмовляти з Путіним.
Думаю, що насамперед Москва вважає, що і європейці, і американці мають зрозуміти,
що діє Кремль на повному серйозі, хоче обговорити деякі питання,
і для цього готовий загострити ситуацію. І цієї мети Путін досяг.
З одного боку, Москві вдалося переконати Байдена, що важливо розмовляти з Путіним.
І американці зрештою поступилися. Найважливіше - продовжувати діалог.
Крім цього можна сказати, що сторони мають різні позиції, і обидві сторони
дали чітко зрозуміти, що позиції змінювати не стануть.
Конфлікт навколо України нікуди не подінеться й у майбутньому.
Експерт вважає, що відеоконференція між Байденом і Путіним стане
новою відправною точкою для подальших переговорів з Москвою щодо цілої низки питань:
від роззброєння до ситуації на Близькому Сході та в Білорусі.
І хоча Байден хотів, ставши президентом, більше сконцентруватися
на тихоокеанському регіоні та Китаї, а взаємини з Росією делегувати європейцям,
наразі йому це, швидше за все, не вдасться.